[Music]
welcome back to cbs
this morning the pandemic has seen an
explosion in
online education but also cheating
a cbs news investigation found an
industry in kenya
that thrives on american students who
pay to cheat
kenyan writers complete college-level
assignments the practice is known as
contract cheating it's illegal in 17
states
but not at the federal level and
enforcement is rare
deborah pata spoke to some kenyan
writers paid to cheat for americans
they ask that we do not use their real
names
cheating in college is nothing new but
as more and more degrees are done online
it's become a billion dollar industry
and the heart of it
is right here in nairobi often using top
class kenyan
graduates who come from poverty like
this
dreams of escaping life's grinding
hardships often go up in smoke here
education is seen as the only way out
and many kenyans go hungry
in order to pay for it but even with a
good degree
it's hard to find work i've been
searching for work since
i finished high school joanne's tuition
fees were due
you can still you have to find something
to do for yourself
william was battling to pay his rent and
so they turned to the global essay for
hire industry
it's not really something you would be
proud about telling people
that you help others cheat
here's how it works the kenyans
advertise their services on reputable
websites with hip
names like ace my homework and essay
jedi
these are legitimate platforms offering
academic assistance like
tutoring but some students use them to
pay writers who will do
anything for them from an urgent essay
to an entire college degree
william has first-hand experience of
this with one client
i did his degree and right now i'm doing
his master's he's promised me that i'm
also going to do it
his phd he's the most successful of the
two earning over two thousand dollars a
month
he pays to open accounts on a few of the
websites
securing work for himself and other
writers
the american student pays between twenty
to fifty dollars a page
the account owner like william takes a
75 percent cut
the kenyan writer can earn as little as
five dollars a page
so the first one is the kenyans are
often given the american students
college login details
so they can complete assignments and
access the university
library they showed us some of these and
we were able to verify that these were
indeed students
enrolled at us universities joanne is
doing
entire courses for some students you
know give me an example of some of the
names of the essays
argumentative essay on
emotional support animals i also did
research on
on the invention of insulin with her
help there passing with distinction
that one of psychology he got nice and
william is writing all the papers for a
social psychology student
who's getting straight a's the kenyans
are so good at the job
that sometimes they get asked to dumb
things down
there is one i did and the student got
97. in lecture i was like this doesn't
look like you
so the student is like could you please
lower it down maybe work on the language
between them
they say they have enabled american
students to cheat their way through
everything from u.s history to
engineering
even medicine i think the state of
cheating
at colleges and at universities is
serious and getting more serious
ethics professor david rettinger has
been sounding the alarm for years
we trust that our doctor has actually
been to medical school
cheating leads us to
overall social corruption because it
leads us to having a
cadre of professionals who can't
actually do the work that they claim
they can do
the kenyan writers say cheating requests
come from students
everywhere small online colleges to
major state universities
they just have the name but then we got
the skills we got the knowledge and we
got the experience
he now wants to quit the cheating
business but with so many kenyans living
in dire poverty
there are plenty of graduates waiting to
take his place
the kenyan students we spoke to believe
it's impossible to shut down the
cheating industry
saying that if websites are closed they
will simply find new ways to operate
for cbs this morning deborah patter
nairobi
kenya we asked the website seen in the
story for comment and haven't received
response the u.s department of education
says their regulations require that
schools
have processes in place to establish
that any student who registers
is the same student who engages in the
program
so many startling aspects of this but
one is like i don't know how
what college students can afford to pay
fifty dollars a page
privileged ones and that's the problem
isn't that right these are like
people barely making it and they're
doing the hard work for people who can
afford to just pay but it'll catch up to
them
i was wondering how how they can police
it if you get the student's id
and you can log on as a student yeah how
can you tell who
who you're talking to right i don't know
how you police it but
listen i didn't even know it had a name
contract cheating i thought the
professor was right where he said it
really is
social corruption i would feel guilty if
if
if i if i succeeded well you're you're a
good person
i don't know about that no your tutor
pump you need your friends no no no
i've had some desperate moments i'll
admit if term papers do
but you didn't do it no i didn't she
didn't do it don't cheat that's the last